now it's your turn to set up the client
IDs so that you can use some my profile
page in your conference central
application after you get everything
hooked up you'll find that more and more
of the web pages start to work as you
add more functionality in the coming
exercises so I'm just going to go over
the things that you need to do to hook
up the web UI to the backend API you're
going to need to get the client ID to do
that just go to the developers console
and in your web in your client ID for
web application you can get your client
ID and then you're going to set the web
client ID in constants Java so that your
endpoints API knows which client IDs are
allowed to access it then you're also
going to add the client ID in app j/s so
that your web UI can identify itself
properly when it goes through the
authentication process and then you're
going to need to make sure that the
developer email and the product name are
set in the consent screen and then also
in the developers console you're going
to need to set the JavaScript
cross-origin so that the client
application knows which URLs are allowed
to access it when they run JavaScript so
this you do in the developers console
these two are in code and these again
you do back in the developer console so
after you've gone through these steps
then deploy your app and you can do it
on localhost or on appspot and then go
to the my profile page and test it and
as you go through each of these steps
come here and just check off the steps
as you do them